[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
schauen wir auf den Nachrichtenthemen
von heute
ja zum europäischen asylpaket
Innenministerin Phaser will für die
geplante reformstimmen dazu gehören auch
harte Maßnahmen an den EU-Außengrenzen
Aufregung um März Aussagen welche
Leistungen bekommen Asylbewerber beim
Zahnarzt viele Politiker sind empört
über die Sicht des
cdu-chefsieg im DFB-Pokal RB Leipzig
wackelt gegen den Zweitligisten Wehen
Wiesbaden sieht aber am Ende mit einem
drei zu zwei in die nächste Runde ein
[Musik]
um illegale Migration zu begrenzen
versucht die EU seit Monaten sich auf
eine Verschärfung des Asylrechts zu
einigen Deutschland blockierte bislang
doch dann gab es gestern einen Appell
des Kanzlers und heute kündigte die
Innenministerin in Brüssel an
zuzustimmen mit der Reform sind künftig
Asylverfahren an den EU-Außengrenzen
vorgesehen kommen besonders viele
geflüchtete soll ein Krisenmechanismus
greifen ein Kernstück der Reform damit
können mehr Menschen länger unter
haftähnlichen Bedingungen festgehalten
werden genau deswegen hatten vor allem
die Grünen Bedenken aus Brüssel Florian
neuhahn
der Sitzungsort ist derselbe wie immer
die Stimmung aber hat sich gedreht
Richtung Abschottung Treffen der EU
Innenminister der Vizepräsident der
EU-Kommission fast den Druck in Wort
wir haben schon zu viele Jahre gekämpft
und sind gescheitert jetzt haben wir die
einzigartige Chance zu handeln und sind
näher an einer Lösung als jemals zuvor
Grund für den Optimismus ein Machtwort
von Bundeskanzler Scholz gestern Berlin
werde sich nicht mehr gegen die geplante
krisenverordnung Stellen bis zuletzt
hatte die Bundesregierung dagegen
argumentiert aus Sorge vor Menschen
unwürdigen Zuständen den Lagern an der
EU Außengrenze nach Stunden Verhandlung
verkündet die Innenministerin heute
Abend in Brüssel sie habe Verbesserungen
herausgehandelt die Verfahren von
Kindern und deren Familien einen
Außengrenzen sollen priorisiert
behandelt werden es sind keine
Abweichung von den normalen
Aufnahmebedingungen nach der
aufnahmerichtlinie möglich
lich am Nachmittag die grüne
Außenministerin sie versucht den
Kompromiss als Erfolg zu verkaufen die
letzten 48 Stunden haben gezeigt wie
wichtig es ist bis zur letzten Minute
als deutsche Ministerin für deutsche
aber auch eben für europäische
Interessen zu kämpfen noch aber wird
weiter verhandelt über die letzten
Details auch das Europaparlament müsste
noch zustimmen
seit acht Jahren streitet Europa über
einen gemeinsames Asylsystem jetzt unter
dem Druck gestiegener Flüchtlingszahlen
rückt es erstmals in greifbare Nähe
dabei ist völlig offen ob allein ein
solches System die Zahlen wirklich
reduzieren kann und so ist das heute
wohl nur ein kleiner Schritt Europa
ringt weiter in der Migrationsfrage
in Deutschland sorgt CDU-Chef Merz
wieder mal mit einer Aussage für
Empörung diesmal geht es um
Zahnbehandlungen für abgelehnte
Asylbewerber im Sender Welt sagte märz
die lassen sich die Zähne neu machen und
die deutschen Bürger nebendran kriegen
keine Termine
dem widerspricht die
Bundeszahnärztekammer Asylbewerber
würden in den ersten 18 Monaten nur bei
akuten schmerzhaften Problemen behandelt
danach bekommen sie Kassenleistungen
eine Komplettsanierung der Zähne ist
darin nicht enthalten Klaus Brodbeck
er hat es wieder getan Fernsehauftritt
gestern Nachmittag es geht um Migration
und Friedrich Merz geht in die Vollen
die werden doch wahnsinnig die Leute
wenn die sehen das 300.000 Asylbewerber
abgelehnt sind nicht ausreißen die
vollen Leistungen bekommen die voller
Heilfürsorge bekommen die sitzen beim
Arzt und lassen sich die Zähne neu
machen und die deutschen Bürger neben
dran kriegen keine Termine was sie hier
machen ist eine Katastrophe für dieses
Land die Reaktionen diesen Nachmittag im
Bundestag entsetzt bis empört
[Applaus]
wie er gestern gemacht hat sind objektiv
falsch und menschlich niederträchtig
meine Damen und Herren ich bin ehrlich
gesagt nicht bereit sie auch nur
andeutungsweise zu wiederholen aber sie
sind auf dem Niveau eines russischen
troll-accounts das ist eine Lüge und
eine falsche Geschichte die da erzählt
und das ist brandgefährlich wenn Sie das
in die Mitte der Gesellschaft tragen und
sie sollten sich davon distanzieren Herr
Merz sie sind mit solchen Aussagen ihres
Amtes einfach nicht würdig NRW
Ministerpräsident wüst CDU stellt sich
hinter März versucht eine Interpretation
Überlastung sehen wir an vielen Stellen
in Kommunen auch in den sozialen
Sicherungssystem ich glaube das ist das
worauf Friedrich Merz Hinweisen wollten
darauf so habe ich ihnen jedenfalls
verstanden März liege falsch betont
hingegen die Bundeszahnärztekammer jetzt
haben wir das
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz und wissen
ganz genau was geht und was nicht dass
ich geflüchtete massenhaft in
Deutschland die Zähne machen lassen wie
Friedrich Merz gesagt hat das geht im
Regelfall nicht der die Debatte
angestoßen hatte zog sich währenddessen
zurück Friedrich Merz gerade lieber
hinter der Bank
Wirbel um die Aussagen des CDU-Chefs
mehr Informationen dazu gibt's in
unserer ZDF heute App die werden
Asylbewerber beim Arzt versorgt oder
welche Leistungen bekommen abgelehnte
Asylbewerber
kritisch ist das Herbstgutachten der
führenden Wirtschaftsinstitute die
Stimmung in den deutschen Unternehmen
habe sich verschlechtert dazu trage auch
die politische Unsicherheit bei vor
allem in den Bereichen Energie und
Klimaschutz im Frühjahr hatten die
Wissenschaftler noch mit einem Wachstum
des Bruttoinlandsprodukts von 0,3%
gerechnet schraubten die Prognose jetzt
aber deutlich runter aktuelle
Einschätzung um 0,6 Prozent könnte die
Wirtschaftsleistung schrumpfen
etwas Entspannung gibt es dagegen bei
den Verbraucherpreisen im September sind
die Preise nach vorläufigen Zahlen um
4,5% gestiegen im Vergleich zum
Vorjahresmonat das ist die niedrigste
Inflationsrate seit Beginn des Ukraine
Kriegs im August waren es noch 6,1
Prozent
Lebensmittelpreise steigen aber weiter
überdurchschnittlich und auch Benzin und
Ölpreise gehen aktuell nach oben Hagen
Nicolas berichtet
wer Volltank zahlt nicht selten eine
dreistellige Summe die hohen
Kraftstoffpreise sind für viele
Autofahrer längst wieder eine
Herausforderung fahren ca 30.000
Kilometer im Jahr und macht sich schon
bemerkbar ob ich dann für zehn Cent
teurer Tanke oder weniger Tanke die
Inflation auch an der Tankstelle spürbar
für Benzin Diesel oder Heizöl greifen
Kunden tief ins Portemonnaie die
Mineralölwirtschaft sieht die Ursache im
angespannten Weltmarkt für Öl
die OPEC hat die Zügel der Förderung
absichtlich angezogen um den Ölpreis
nach oben zu treiben das macht sich beim
weltweiten Kraftstoffpreis bemerkbar
nicht nur in Deutschland und bei Diesel
haben wir die spezielle Situation dass
wir nicht die Mengen bekommen die wir in
den Vorjahren hatten auch das mit Folgen
für die künftige Inflationsrate auch der
Heizölpreis steigt Brennstoffhändler
erwarten zum Winter hin keine
Entspannung die Preise werden weiterhin
steigen und es ist kurzfristig
eigentlich wichtig Heizöl momentan
einzukaufen weil die Kapazitäten werden
auch zum Jahresende wieder knapp die
Inflation auch Thema bei der Konferenz
der Energieminister in Wernigerode als
Mittel gegen hohe Energiepreise fordern
sie vom Bund Verbraucher beim Strompreis
weiter zu entlasten eine Möglichkeit
besteht darin die Stromsteuer in
Deutschland bzw abzusenken auf das
europäische Mindestmaß das scheint mir
eine gute Maßnahme damit es auch für
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher spürbar
wird vorerst bleibt Energie selber für
die Inflation und die Preise auch an der
Tankstelle hoch
als Reaktion auf den russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine bekommt
Deutschland in zwei Jahren eine
zusätzliche Raketenabwehr
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
unterschrieb in Berlin den Kaufvertrag
für das israelische System Arrow 3 dabei
zerstören
lenkflugkörperfeindliche Objekte in
großer Höhe drei Arrow 3 Systeme kauft
Deutschland von Israel die kosten fast 4
Milliarden Euro
die armenische Enklave Bergkarabach wird
es ab Januar nicht mehr geben sie hat
ihre Selbstauflösung angekündigt das ist
Teil der
Kapitulationsbedingungen also bei John
hatte in der vergangenen Woche mit einer
blitz-offensive die vollständige
Kontrolle über die Kaukasusregion
übernommen seitdem ist weit mehr als die
Hälfte der rund 120.000 armenischen
Einwohner Berg karabachs geflohen Armin
Körper
ein Mann wird abgeführt es ist Truppen
war dann Jan bis Februar war er
Regierungschef der selbsternannten
Republik Bergkarabach jetzt bitte vor
laufender Kamera von aserbaidschanischen
Kräften festgenommen pikant er war vor
seinem Amt hier Russe und einer der
reichsten noch dazu doch den russischen
Pass hat er abgegeben und der Kreml hat
die Seiten gewechselt und lässt ihn
mitsamt seine Miniaturstadt einfach
untergehen
wir befinden uns in einem neuen
Koordinatensystem wir sind im Kontakt
mit unseren Partnern in Aserbaidschan
und verfolgen besonders die humanitäre
Lage mit Russland schaut Armeniens
einstige Schutzmacht also zu wie
Aserbaidschan Fakten schafft
Bergkarabach das offiziell nie anerkannt
wurde soll bis Jahresende aufhören zu
existieren
die Menschen die davon gekommen sind
können nicht fassen dass ihr Start heute
auch von den eigenen Führern aufgegeben
wurde
ich habe doch gekämpft für diesen Staat
sogar Medaillen erhalten das kann doch
nicht sein aber wir haben unsere Toten
zu betrauern ich kann nichts mehr sagen
unsere Jungs sind dafür gefallen wenn
das alles so ist wofür dann nur unsere
armen Jungs
Eigentums
Haus und Heimat haben sie verloren jetzt
auch noch ihr Land die Welt hat sich
abgewandt von der selbsternannten
Republik Bergkarabach deren Existenz 32
Jahre lang einfach irgendwie hingenommen
wurde
der ride lively with Award auch
alternativer Nobelpreis genannt ist eine
Auszeichnung für die Gestaltung einer
besseren Welt in diesem Jahr geht der
unter anderem an die
seenotrettungsorganisation
von Flüchtlingen außerdem geehrt werden
eine Frauenrechtlerin und
abtreibungsärztin aus Ghana und auch
umweltaktivistinnen aus Kambodscha und
aus Kenia
die katholische Kirche hat
Missbrauchsopfer dazu aufgerufen sich
auch Jahre nach den Taten zu melden
alles solle auf den Tisch kommen auch
wenn dann die Denkmäler fallen sagte der
Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz betzing mit Blick auf
den Fall Hengsbach dem 1991 verstorbenen
Kardinal und Bischof von Essen wird
bislang Missbrauch in drei Fällen
vorgeworfen
viele Eltern bekommen es gar nicht mit
wenn sich jemand im Netz an ihre Kinder
heranpirscht auch Eileens Mutter sagt
sie hätte zwar bemerkt dass ihre Tochter
viel am Handy ist dachte aber dass sie
nur tiktok Videos schaut
Eileens Mörder hat die 14-Jährige online
kontaktiert Nacktfotos gefordert er hat
sie erpresst und schließlich getötet
heute wurde er zu lebenslanger Haft mit
Sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt Susanne
Santina
es war im Juli letzten Jahres als die
14-Jährige Alien plötzlich spurlos
verschwand nach einer Woche intensiver
Suche wurde ihre Leiche schließlich an
diesem See in der hessischen Wetterau
gefunden durch die Auswertung von
Eileens Handy Daten kam die Ermittler
schnell auf die Spur von Jan p
der 30-Jährige wurde heute unter anderem
wegen Mordes und versuchte
Vergewaltigung zu lebenslange Haft
verurteilt zudem stellte das Gericht die
besondere Schwere der Schuld fest und
ordnete eine anschließende
Sicherungsverwahrung an gerechtfertigt
so die Staatsanwaltschaft keinerlei Reue
keinerlei Empathie im Gegenteil er hat
nach der Tötung von alinen sich
eigentlich vor seinem geistigen Auge
schon wieder ein nächstes Opfer gesucht
und hat am nächsten Tag auch
sexualisierte Videos schon an weitere
junge Mädchen geschickt
im Internet mehr als 7000 sexualisierte
Nachrichten geschrieben sie unter Druck
gesetzt sich auch mit ihm zu treffen
durch den Prozess ist das Phänomen des
cyber-roomings in den Fokus gerückt
erwachsene Männer versuchen in Internet
schätzt das Vertrauen von unerfahrenen
Mädchen zu gewinnen um sie sexuell
gefügig zu machen Berlin hat deshalb
Roaming einen tödlichen Ausgang wir
können erkennen im Rahmen der
Ermittlungen dass das ein Phänomen ist
was immer mehr zunimmt und was für junge
Mädchen die besonders naiv sind
besonders anfällig sind sehr große
Gefahren mit sich bringt
als 14-Jähriger versucht ein elfjähriges
Mädchen zu vergewaltigen verbrachte zehn
Jahre in der Psychiatrie der 30-Jährige
wird jetzt wohl mindestens 15 Jahre
hinter Gittern sitzen
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen mehr Geld
neue Perspektiven auf dem Pflegetag in
Berlin diskutieren etwa 7000
teilnehmende wie Pflegeberufe
attraktiver werden können schon jetzt
dauert es im Schnitt
230 Tage bis die Stelle einer
Krankenpflegekraft neu besetzt ist es
hat sich aber auch schon was getan zeigt
Nikola Albrecht
trotz dünner Personaldecke ist die
Stimmung an diesem Morgen gut auf
Station 3 des Alexianer Fachkrankenhaus
für Altersmedizin in Potsdam
Sandra meye trianca Filou leitet die
Station seit vielen Jahren die
Mitarbeiter die wir haben sind
hochmotiviert und top engagiert aber wir
haben viel mehr offene Stellen und wir
wissen gar nicht wie wir die Stellen
besetzen können weil gar kein Nachwuchs
kommt das so eine große Sorge die uns
umtreibt wie wir die Patienten hier mit
dem wenigen Personal überhaupt adäquat
pflegen können auf dem deutschen
Pflegetag in Berlin machen die
präsentierten Zahlen und Fakten deutlich
es bewegt sich zwar etwas im
Pflegebereich aber nicht genug immerhin
ist im Jahr 2022 die Zahl der
Beschäftigten Pflegefachkräfte um 18.000
im Vergleich zum Vorjahr gestiegen
dennoch gab es rund 37.000 vakantische
Stellen Tendenz steigend und
4100 Menschen weniger haben eine
Ausbildung zur Pflegefachkraft begonnen
deutlicher Auswirkungen haben offenbar
die jüngsten Tariferhöhungen zwischen 11
und 16% mehr Lohn sorgen für mehr
Zufriedenheit der Nebeneffekt noch mehr
Pflegekräfte entscheiden sich aktuell
für Teilzeit das Reise weitere Lücken in
den Dienstplan aber auch positive Folgen
wenn die Mitarbeiter guten Millionen
bekommen können Sie sich auch eher
leisten die Arbeitszeit zu reduzieren
auch schon früher vielleicht und bleiben
aber so länger im Beruf und das finde
ich eigentlich viel wichtiger weil sie
bei der motiviert sind vielleicht ein
Modell das auch junge Menschen attraktiv
finden hoffen Sie hier
und jetzt Fußball DFB-Pokal da hat es
nach den Bayern gestern auch
Titelverteidiger Leipzig in die zweite
Runde geschafft zum München wirklich nur
mit Müh und Not RB am Ende mit einem
glücklichen drei zu zwei Sieg beim
Zweitligisten wie in Wiesbaden denn die
Hessen die werden sich nach allen Regeln
der Fußballkunst
wen Wiesbaden in rot steckt gegen den
Favoriten nie auf nach 0:2 der
sehenswerte Anschlusstreffer zum 1:2
durch Britain Leipzig nach der Halbzeit
zu behäbig auch wenn der alte zwei Tore
Vorsprung wiederhergestellt wird Cesco
3:1 für Leipzig aber Britta ihn zum
zweiten trotz gulaschi Parade drei zu
zwei nur noch für Leipzig wen in dem
Ausgleich sogar nahe Leipzig zittert
sich in die zweite Pokalrunde
und am Ende ja hat man auch die Chance
vielleicht Unentschieden zu machen wir
haben richtig ich glaube ein richtig
heißen pokalzeit gesehen trotzdem
untröstlich wenigstens doppelter Schütze
der kroateien
Schock für das deutsche turnalager
wenige Tage vor dem Auftakt der WM in
antwerten Routine Andreas Tober hat sich
beim Training am Knie verletzt und fällt
für die Titel Kämpfer aus bei der WM
geht es für die deutschen Männer und
Frauenmannschaften auch für die
Olympia-Tickets für Paris
Basketball Bundesliga da hat der Meister
aus Ulm standesgemäß die neue Saison mit
einem Sieg eröffnet 90 zu 85 gegen
Chemnitz der Titelverteidiger
tatsächlich aber phasenweise schwer
gegen mutig Aufspielen des Sachsen
die Bundesliga startet auf der Welle
weltmeisterlicher Euphorie und der
deutsche Meister mit Körben wie diesen
von mit 16 Punkten besten Ulmer
karimiano doch auch Chemnitz für diese
Saison hoch gehandelt ist zu Beginn gut
drauf führt mit 15 zu 12 dem deutschen
Meister gelingt dann einen offensivlauf
nach dem ersten Viertel steht es so 31
zu 24 doch entscheidend absetzen können
sich die Ulmer nicht kurz vor Schluss
kommt Chemnitz sogar noch mal auf drei
Punkte dran doch der Meister behält die
Nerven und kann das Auftaktspiel etwas
glücklich für sich entscheiden
also zweimal glückliche Siege gestern
Abend im Basketball und Fußball danke
schön
auch morgen wird's mit um die 25 Grad
sehr warm Details hat gleich Christa
Augen das heute journal um 9:45 Uhr mit
Christian Sievers wir danken für Ihr
Interesse und wünschen noch einen
schönen Abend bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend ja was für Temperaturen für
Ende September in Freiburg im Breisgau
erreichen wir morgen wieder über 25 Grad
dann überquert uns eine Kaltfront am
Samstag sind die Temperaturen etwas
gedämpfter der nächste warmluftvorstoß
steht aber schon bereit und Anfang der
neuen Woche erreichen wir an die 30 Grad
Marke im Südwesten des Landes und dann
ist es immerhin schon Anfang Oktober
auch heute Nacht ist es recht mild bei
11 bis 15 Grad im Süden kühlt es auch
auf 7 Grad ab hier ist es klar
stellenweise gibt es Nebel aus
Nordwesten kommen jetzt immer mehr
Wolken ins Land in der zweiten
Nachthälfte beginnt es auch schon etwas
zu regnen und der Regen kommt dann im
Laufe des Tages in Richtung Mitte voran
auch mit Wolkenburg auffrischendem Wind
dahinter folgen Schauer und kurze
Gewitter alles in allem kommt aber nicht
viel vom Himmel und es gibt auch
zwischendurch trockene Phasen im Süden
kommt die Kaltfront noch nicht an da
gibt's nach Nebel Auflösung noch mal
Sonne und das sorgt für große Temperatur
im Unterschied an der See gibt es teils
keine 20 Grad in Richtung Lausitz und im
Süden sommerliche 25 bis 29 Grad am
Samstag verabschiedet sich der September
wie gesagt etwas kühler aber in den
ersten Oktobertagen machen sich im Süden
schon wieder die Spätsommer Gefühle
breit im Norden ist das etwas
unbeständiger und damit auf Wiedersehen